nowhere in ukraine is safe from russian
aggression
moments after the sound of jets broke a
peaceful afternoon in the western city
of lev
we watched flames rip through a fuel
depot after two missiles struck
the attack fell just short of the city's
television tower
it's not clear if this may have been the
intended target
but it wasn't over
with more strikes can you see soon after
as we were preparing to go on air behind
us came the sound of more explosions
the second hit was a military depot on
the outskirts of the city
but the smoke billowing behind us
has broken the confidence that levith is
a city of sanctuary
this is a first strike on a populated
civilian area of a city that's offered a
safe haven to so many an unsettling
development for people who fled from
untold horrors in other areas of the
country but also perhaps not a
coincidence that the strike comes at a
time where president biden the leader of
the free world isn't far from here just
across the border over in poland
this is something few expected here but
many feared
and shortly after the first attack panic
and suspicion were rife we witnessed
several arrests there's a lack of trust
that people could be helping the
russians
at a time where russian ground forces
have failed in many areas of the country
a reminder they've advanced in the
eastern donbass and the south
lev's mayor confirming this attack on
his city were from rockets fired from
crimea's largest city the area annexed
by russia in 2014.
i underline one more time we don't know
what is the next target of the russian
rockets which were fired today from the
city of sevastopol today they hit many
times facilities in the vive as well as
in the country all of us are in the same
situation the faster we receive quality
weapons and air defense weapons the
safer our cities and citizens will be
lev has become a refuge for so many
families already traumatized by war
this attack may have been a message to
the west
but it's shattered a sense of safety
in the city so many have come to for
protection
sally lockwood sky news lev in western
ukraine